inquiétude à tchernobyl huit ans après
la catastrophe la centrale attend
toujours les travaux de réfection des
experts internationaux viennent
d'ailleurs de demander sa fermeture pure
et simple mais les autorités refusent
pour l'instant d'envisager cette
fermeture de la centrale les ukrainiens
demande en revanche une aide financière
internationale pour assurer la sécurité
des réacteurs qui sont toujours en
fonctionnement
jean jacques peyraud huit ans après la
catastrophe de tchernobyl la centrale
maudite
ou plutôt ce qu'il en reste fonctionne
encore à plein régime et au fil des mois
deux menaces se précisent
la première sur ce fameux sarcophage de
béton qui recouvre les ruines de la
tranche 4
celle qui a explosé en 86 selon tous les
experts qui ont inspecté le site
cette coquille de protection ne
résistera pas au delà de 5 à 10 ans
deuxième menace vient des réacteurs qui
continue de produire de l'énergie
d'abord parce qu'ils sont accolés au
sarcophage ensuite parce que les
incidents s'y multiplient une
quarantaine
en un an le fait quand même pas mal de
temps qu'on va donc on attire
l'attention sur le fait que cette
centrale terme et dangereuse
un certain nombre d'incidents sont
produits récemment nous ont dit il vaut
mieux l'arrêter dans ces conditions là
ces réacteurs de conception ancienne
n'ont pas été améliorées comme on l'a
fait en russie le problème est financier
et l'ukraine n'a pas non plus les moyens
de fermer thierno bim qui fournit 7 % de
son énergie
cinq centrales de remplacement sont en
chantier mais il manque 20 milliards de
francs pour les achever
on conseille de quand même d'essayer
d'obtenir un engagement relativement
précis relativement ferme des ukrainiens
en et en échange ou en contrepartie ce
qui est normal de l'unm qui leur
permettrait de faire démarrer d'autres
sources d'énergie le gouvernement
ukrainien confirme qu'il est conscient
des dangers de tchernobyl mais il attend
l'aide financière occidentale pour avoir
les moyens de les conjurés une haie